ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRO BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY
NAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS ME. MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED.
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND ASHA. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF VALENTINE
REFLECTION. WHEN I WAS FIRST
DATING BOB IN LOS ANGELES
ALMOST FORTY YEARS AGO I WORK
FOR AN AEROSPACE COMPANY CALLED
T. R. W. ON ONE OF OUR EARLY
DATE HE PICKED ME UP RIGHT
AFTER WORK. WE WENT TO A BEARD.
AREA THAT WAS SHOWING ZATO ICHI
THE BLIND SWORDSMAN. FANS OF
THAT THE ET NOTE THAT IN EACH
OF HIS MANY MOVIES HE WOULD EAT
LIKE HIS MEALS WERE FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN. IT MIGHT BE A BOWL OF
RICE IN OFTEN IT WAS A HUGE
BASEBALL THAT WE CALL WHEN YOU
GET. START TO EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
ENTHUSIASM THEIR RIGHTS WOULD
COLLECT ALL OVER HIS FACE. IT
ALWAYS LOOKS SO DELICIOUS. I
RECALL WE WENT TO THE EARLY
SHOWING BECAUSE IT WAS RIGHT
AFTER WORK IN I WAS GETTING
HUNGRY BUT IT WAS EARLY IN ARE
DATING AND I WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE MOVIE. I
REMEMBER WHAT IN THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN SEEN ZATO ICHI WITH
GOBBLING DOWN THIS HUGE BONY
GIDDY RICE BALL. IT WAS THEN
THAT BOB LEANED OVER AND SAID
TO ME. BOY THEY'RE SURE LOOKS
GOOD. I AGREE. THEN HE ASKED.
DO YOU WANT IN ONLY GIDDY. I
SAID OR YELL. AND THEN HE
REACHED INTO HIS JACKET POCKET
AND PULLED OUT TO ONLY GIDDY
AND HANDED ONE TO ME. IT WAS
EVEN MORE DELICIOUS WATCHING
THOUGHT TO ICHI EATING HIS OWN
A GIDDY AS WE DEVOUR OURS. THAT
WAS A MEMORABLE DATE BECAUSE
THAT EVENING I SAID THOSE THREE
LITTLE WORDS TO BOB FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME. WHEN HE HANDED
ME THE ONLY GIDDY. I LOOKED AT
HIM AND SAID. YEAR SO WEIRD. I
THINK THAT MAY HAVE BEEN ONE OF
THE FIRST MOMENT I THOUGHT. IT
MIGHT BE INTERESTING TO BE WITH
THIS STRANGE MAN. AND FOR
DECADES LATER I AM STILL
GRATEFUL FOR THE LAUGHTER WE
CONTINUE TO SHARE FOR LAUGHTER
I'VE COME TO FEEL IS ESSENTIAL
TO LOVE. NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER
TWO WHAT KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS. THANK YOU
REVEREND ESTA BUT I FIND
BLESSING FOR VALENTINE'S DAY WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
NUMBER IS PLEASE JOIN ME TO
SALUTE OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I SEE.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY RECENTLY
MET AT SEVEN AM OTHER CALDERON
MOVES A MISTER GROSS SECONDS AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR MATERNITY LEAVE ASSEMBLY%
MEMBER CERVANTES ON LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAY
COM LONGER AND THE MOAN. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GONZALEZ HOLDEN IRWIN
MURATSUCHI RODRIGUEZ WICKS. AND
WOOD. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COOLEY AND BIGELOW AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS. TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES TO HAVE
GUESTS SEATED AT HER DESK TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GALLAGHER AND MULLIN TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN MEMBER TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE OR- MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY. TODAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IT'S AN HONOR TO WORK WELCOME
GUEST FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS JOINING US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY ONE HUNDRED YEARS AGO
THE FOUNDERS OF THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA WERE
BEATEN JAILED AND TORTURED IN
THEIR MOVEMENT TO GIVE WOMEN
THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND TO BE
ENFRANCHISED IN SHAPING THE
LAWS AND POLICIES GOVERNING
THEIR LIVES TODAY THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IS
STILL FIGHT FOR VOTING RIGHTS.
DISTRICTS INEVITABLE POLICY
THIS IS HOW YOU THAT IN MY LOS
WE HAVE SEVERAL RINGS AND THEY
ARE EXTREMELY ACTIVE HOLDING
CANDIDATE FORMS OF HITTING ON
THE ABOUT MEASURES FEELS LIKE
FOR AND A OUT THERE TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC ABOUT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IT'S MY PLEASURE
DIRECT I TO.
THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN AND WELCOME TO THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. AT
USING MITHRAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SO I HAVE
THE DISTINCT HONOR OF
INTRODUCING TO YOU MY BELOVED
MY ONE AND ONLY MY SON
CHRISTOPHER RAY IS. WELCOME
CHRISTOPHER.
MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN FILE ITEMS ONE THREE
THREE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR
H. R. SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
MISTER CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
TO PRESENT A COMMITMENTS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT ITS TWO HR SEVEN. ON
BEHALF. MEMBER MARTUCCI THESE
MOMENTS ARE TECHNICAL CLARIFY
NATURE ASSET THE MINUTES BE
ADOPTED AND THAT THE BILL GO
OUT TO PRINCE AND BE BACK ON
FILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT IN BACK TO FILE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. ITEMS THIS.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM SIX AND
SEVEN DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
THREE BY SELLING MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO ENGINEERS WEEK. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL ALL IS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE BELL
DID NOT RING BUT WE ARE VOTING
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS
AND VETS ARE BEING REGISTERED.
WHICH IS NOT HERE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS
WE ARE VOTING ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FIFTY FIVE NEW ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE I FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO. NOW MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH IS A
HOLIDAY PRESIDENT'S DAY.
TUESDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM HAVE A
WONDERFUL VALENTINE'S DAY AND
PRESIDENT'S DAY MEMBERS IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY KNOWN THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR
GERMANS IN MEMORY OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN
LIFTED. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR OR
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON IN IN GERMANY
MEMORY. MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR TURN. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY WITH DEEP SADNESS TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS
TURNING THE MEMORY OF FORMER
SAN MATTEO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JIM FOX JIM PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY NINTH. AT AGE
SEVENTY FIVE. IT HAD DEVOTED
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF HIS LIFE
TO SERVING AS SAN MATTEO
COUNTY'S TOP PROSECUTOR. THE
SON OF PARENTS WHO IMMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES FROM
IRELAND JIM WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN HALF MOON BAY. GRADUATED
FROM MY ALMA MATER WE NEVER SIR
HIGH SCHOOL SAN MATTEO HE SOON
WENT ON TO EARN HIS BACHELORS
AND LAW DEGREES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
HAVING ENVISIONED A FUTURE
CAREER IN LAW HE BEGAN HIS
DECADES LONG PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER AS A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
BEFORE ENTERING INTO PRIVATE
PRACTICE. HE WAS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO WHEN SUCCESSFULLY
RAN A CONTESTED ELECTION FOR
THE POSITION OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
WHAT'S REAL IT HANDLES SIX MORE
TIMES BEFORE. HIRING IN TWENTY
TWO TEN. THROUGHOUT HIS SEVEN
TERMS AS SAN MATTEO COUNTY'S
TOP PROSECUTOR. JIM WAS WELL
KNOWN AND RESPECTED BY THOSE IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR HIS
UNPARALLELED WORK ETHIC.
DEDICATION TO PROMOTING JUSTICE
AND TREMENDOUS CHARACTER. HE
WAS ALSO KNOWN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP THE STATE WIDE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
JIM INSPIRED MANY WITH HIS
UNQUESTIONED INTEGRITY AND
DEDICATION TO HIS VALUES. HE
SERVED AS A MENTOR TO MANY WHO
HAVE UNDOUBTEDLY BEEN TOUCHED
DEEPLY. BY HIS WORK HE WAS A
LONGTIME RESIDENT OF SAN CARLOS
WHERE HE LIVES WITH HIS WIFE OF
OVER FIFTY YEARS BONNIE.
TOGETHER THEY RAISE THEIR
CHILDREN CHRISTINE. TIM AND
BRIAN. JIM LONG BE REMEMBERED
FIRST CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE JUSTICE AND SERVE THE
NEEDS OF MANY THROUGHOUT SAN
MATTEO COUNTY. HE WAS A GIANT
IN THE LEGAL AND BROADER
COMMUNITIES. BUT NEVER LOST HIS
COMMON IN CARING TOUCH. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF JIM FOX.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. RON
BRAZIER WENT TO BE WITH THE
LORD. ON JANUARY THIRTIETH THE
BROKEN IN THE LOST. THE
OUTCASTS IN THE HOMELESS. LOOK
FOR HIM AND HE WASN'T THERE.
BUT THEY WERE NOT SAD. IN THE
MOMENT OF HIS ABSENCE FROM HIS
BODY. HIS TIRED EARTHLY BODY.
HE WAS INSTANTLY WITH OUR
SAVIOR JESUS CHRIST. RON
FRAZIER WAS A SERVANT. MORE IN
OKLAHOMA AS A YOUNG MAN HE
SERVED HIS COUNTRY IN VIETNAM.
RETURNING AFTER RETURNING FROM
WAR LEFT MANY SCARS LIKE MANY
OF THAT GENERATION. RON WENT
THROUGH IT. THREE TOURS IN
VIETNAM WILL DO THAT TO YOU.
IT'S WHY HE HAD SUCH A HARD.
FOR VETERANS AND ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE WHO HAD BEEN BROKEN DOWN
BY PTSD AND SELF MEDICATING
WITH DRUGS AND ALCOHOL. WHEN
RON HEARD THE GOOD NEWS FROM A
GOOD FRIEND. HIS LIFE CHANGED
FOREVER. YOU SEE JESUS HEALS
THE WOUNDS THAT CANNOT BE
HEALED. HE BECAME A SERVANT OF
GOD AND OTHERS. NEVER IN MY
LIFE OF A MET SOMEONE MORE
DEDICATED. TO HELPING THE LEAST
OF THESE. RON FOUNDED A HAND UP
MINISTRIES AND THE RIVER
BOTTOMS CHURCH DEDICATED. TO
PROVIDING COMPASSION. AND JOB
AND SKILLS TRAINING TO HELP
BRING PEOPLE UP AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. FREE UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU CAN GIVE A MAN BRED
BUT MAN DOES NOT LIVE ON BREAD
ALONE. BUT ON EVERY WORD THAT
COMES OUT OF THE MOUTH OF GOD.
AND BOTTOMS CHURCH. RUN FED HIS
SHEEP. WE KNEW THAT THE GOSPEL
HAD THE POWER TO TRANSFORM
LIVES. TO BRING US OUT OF THE
MY RE CLAY IN INTO THE FULL
LIGHT OF GOD'S AMAZING GRACE.
THAT IS WHAT MOTIVATED RON MORE
THAN ANYTHING. ANY TOLD
EVERYONE ABOUT IT. LIKE THE
JOHNNY CASH SONG HE TOLD THE
RAMBLER IN THE GAMBLER IN THE
BACK BITER. HE EXHIBITED LOVE
WHENEVER I WOULD SEE RON. HE
WOULD ALWAYS GREET ME WITH A
HUG AND A KISS ON THE CHEEK. HE
WOULD ENCOURAGE ME AND HE WOULD
SAY I LOVE YOU BROTHER. IN THE
LAST YEARS OF HIS LIFE HE
BATTLED CANCER. REALLY FOR MANY
YEARS AND CONTINUE TO BEAT IT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. AND HE
WOULD HE WOULD ALWAYS TELL YOU
KNOW GOD BEAT IT GOD STILL HAS
WORKED FOR ME. TO DO. YOUR AS A
CANCER. TOOK FROM HIS BODY ROM
GOT SMALLER. BUT GOD GOT BIGGER.
WHEN CANCER TOOK HIS HIS VOICE.
HE PREACHED THE GOSPEL EVEN
LOUDER. AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
RON IN THAT MOMENT WHEN RON.
WAS ABSENT FROM THE BODY IN
PRESENT WITH CHRIST HE HEARD
THE WORDS. WELL DONE GOOD AND
FAITHFUL SERVANT. RON BRAZIER I
KNOW I WILL SEE YOU AGAIN. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE IMPACT YOU
HAD ON ALL OF OUR LIVES. MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. OF RON
BRAZIER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED THE
JOURNAL ALL RECALL DURING WILL
BE READ IT INTO AN ALL ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTION
SHOULD BE CONTINUED SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MR MULLIN MOVES IN
MISTER GALLAGHER SECONDS AT THE
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
TUESDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH AT
ONE PM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL.